my lad Shaq will oh no he he thinks he's
bad he doesn't want to link me I'm ready
to link him now you understand what I'm
saying I've dealt with my lacking it's
like dividing the life you know I'm
saying that Shaq is expired
do you understand yes your career is
over big money genistein there's a new
man in town and country you came and
spotted it up spotted up you don't know
yeah yeah yo you done know this big shot
boom I'm not even gonna waste my time
and rap man she's gonna poop over this
yo all right you've done no boom let's
go yeah all right yo Saku oh no yeah
you think a bad so the knees are made of
steel but you're not the moist
Monsieur off it dripping in the changing
room yeah all right cool big shock
we're not big shock you teach back
[Music]
I'm Finn I don't see you see
fungus beat link me yo sabado look at
your toe nose they're black mouth is
white like crack you don't want to see
me in the lab man put your head
let's slap you're done no man don't even
waste my time like I said I don't send
gonna throw I'm sayin man just drop me
in the booth fresh off the dome yo hotel
you're not gonna come get me
man cool big shack where you fight
enroll by yourself you need your
bodyguards I mean I'm in America big
money WOB one come with me brother
Oh tight Jersey old fat Buster Ram
Oh type Puff Daddy attack dj khaled my
brother
Oh tight cardi B you don't know the -
bang bang
[Music]